So here's a hot take about all of this discussion
about putting religion into school.
You're gonna make everyone dumber,
which is already a problem with the American public education system,
but is going to be further perpetuated by making religion.
And let's be serious. We're not talking about religion.
We're talking about Christianity.
Um, a mandatory thing in schools.
With the introduction of the Ten Commandments into school,
um, with prayer.
And now I just saw that Oklahoma
is pushing to have the Bible taught in public education.
Now, before you come with your pitchforks,
I am a religious person. I am Jewish.
I am religiously practicing.
I believe in the Ten Commandments.
My children go to religious school.
But I never want religion taught,
especially any of the major three Abrahamic religions
taught in public school. Number one,
because school is for everyone.
It is a publicly funded environment
that should cater to everybody's educational needs.
Not every student needs to be taught the Christian Bible.
Number two, teaching the Bible comes in one of two ways.
One, you're being taught the Bible as doctrine,
so as unrefutable fact.
Okay, so what that calls for in your students is, like,
a suspended disbelief. Because let's be serious,
under the lens of modern scientific understanding,
there's a lot to question there.
So if it is being taught as irrefutable facts,
you are therefore, like,
limiting your children's development of critical thinking skills
and analytic observation. Now,
if we're using It as a moral compass.
I'm under the impression that teaching your children religion
and especially religious morality
in all of the ways that those are wrapped up together
is a parents prerogative. That is not a state right.
It would be much more useful for students
to be learning things like ethics,
especially when it comes to ethics in business,
than it ever would be to be using the Christian Bible
as a moral compass for all students
in a public education setting.
There are options for schooling
for people who want a religious education,
and I think that is wonderful.
But a public education
should both be welcoming to everyone within the public
and be fostering skills
that will be useful as a member of the general public
later on. Which I think includes critical thinking skills,
media literacy, and ethics as a code of conduct.
All religion in school is a bad idea when it comes to public education,
and we're gonna be dumber because of it.